Today’s air conditioning and refrigeration
systems essentially follow
the same principles that have been around
for about hundred years.
If we continue along today’s path
then that sets us up for a future where
air conditioning
may actually become one of our single largest
sources of greenhouse gas emissions later this century.
Air conditioners have become inescapable
part of our cities.
They operate thanks to refrigerants - chemicals which
when released into the atmosphere are potent
greenhouse gases.
AC units also require huge amounts of energy.
The U.S. uses more electricity for cooling
than Africa does for everything.
As it becomes affordable
for millions more people,
the problems that come with AC will only get worse.
Which is why scientists around the world are
searching for solutions.
Here at the National University of Singapore
professor Chua and his team
are completely rethinking air conditioning.
We need a quantum leap in air conditioning
to save energy, secondly to save our environment.
What we have in the lab is next generation
of air conditioners
which is extremely environmentally friendly,
less energy intensive,
it doesn’t eject heat to the environment
and doesn’t need the chemical refrigerant.
It’s a water based air conditioning.
It requires only one litre of water to operate
for 20 hours.
And you can use rainwater to power up the system.
But there is a limitation.
The air needs to be dry before you can carry
out this process in an efficient way.
And that’s why there are
two separate stages in this AC.
First it dries the air,
using membranes that filter the moisture.
Then the water inside the unit evaporates
taking heat with it.
It’s close to what most of us experience
every day - sweating.
This system uses 30% less energy than
a traditional air conditioner
and it’s also expected to be 30% cheaper.
Crucially, it uses no refrigerants.
And although it’s not available yet, the
government is backing this project,
betting that soon it could be a breath of
fresh air for Singapore and beyond.
Across the other side of the world, one start-up
in California is looking
towards outer space to revolutionise cooling.
And they’re about to test their breakthrough
in the field.
Right now if we measure the temperature of
our surface, it’s around 48 degrees Fahrenheit
and the air temperature is 60 Fahrenheit.
We’re not evaporating water and we’re
not using any electricity.
You can see we’re in a middle of a field
and it is just a thin film coating that enables
this cooling effect and it does this 24 hours a day,
7 days a week.
SkyCool Systems is commercialising
a technology that harnesses
the cold of the sky and space
to enable electricity-free cooling,
as implausible as that may sound at first glance.
The way it works is it takes advantage of
a natural phenomenon
that allows a surface that’s looking up
to the sky to essentially send out some of its heat.
Nearly everything on earth gives off heat
in the form of infrared radiation.
SkyCool’s panels act as high-tech mirrors
reflecting some of that heat
out to the cold expanse of space,
allowing a surface to dip below the temperature
of the surrounding air.
SkyCool’s multilayered film means that it’s
now possible to achieve even during the day.
The panels could be added
onto today’s cooling systems
reducing their energy use
by as much as 20 percent.
The energy we use for cooling is expected
to grow six fold by the year 2050.
And it’s primarily gonna be driven in warmer countries
where air conditioning use is not prevalent today.
What excites us about our technology is that
it represents a unique
and completely different way of handling the
cooling problem
by taking use of a resource that's always
been there, the fact that space is cold.
It's almost like this has been literally over
our heads for centuries, millennia,
but it’s something we’ve not been able
to use as a technology.
With the demand for air conditioning skyrocketing,
using water and the cold of outer space
may turn out to be the best bet we have for
our warming cities.